VAN RIPER: Hi, I'm Van Riper.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: And
I'm Adriana Cerundolo,
Community Manager
for the GDG Program.
I want to first wish you a very
happy new year, and happy 2015.
Really excited for this year.
And I also hope you all had
a wonderful holiday season,
for all of you who celebrated.
VAN RIPER: And with a
new year sometimes comes
change, and we have
a change to announce.
I'm going to be taking a new
position at Google, working
with communities
inside of Google
around mindfulness practices.
It's actually a very
exciting opportunity for me,
but it does mean
that going forward,
you'll be coming solely to
Adriana about GDG support.
And of course, with
Sarah, supporting her.
I just want reaffirm to you
all that my leaving the program
does not indicate any less
support from Google for this.
In fact, if anything,
support is greater
than it's ever been
inside of Google.
I can tell you from my
early days here at Google,
there were times when there were
some questions about whether we
should be investing
in this program.
At this point, with
the impact this program
has had for us, that's
no longer question.
It's more about, how does Google
invest in these communities,
and how do we work best
with these communities?
That's really what's going on.
You see these new
things going on,
like the study jam
program as we're
exploring new ways to
work with the community
and scale our efforts,
and at the same time
provide opportunities
to you in the community.
So I just want to underscore
that-- in fact, I probably
wouldn't be leaving if
I felt that there were
things that were not going well.
The very fact that
I'm leaving is
made possible by the health
of the program within Google.
So I just wanted
to underscore that.
I do want to say this-- it was
a very hard decision for me.
This program has been
a labor of love for me.
I know many of you I
consider close friends now,
and I hope that we will
continue our friendship.
This is not a goodbye.
This is more of a
we-will-meet-again situation.
And I know to the extent
that I can be involved,
I would like to stay
involved on an, obviously,
less formal basis.
So you may not be rid
of me completely yet,
but I have every
confidence in Adriana
in taking this program forward.
I think I'd like
to take this time
to actually use this
as a teachable moment,
because one of the
things I feel really
good about in the situation is
the way that Adriana and I have
worked together and really
shared responsibility
for this program over
the last two years
so that she knows this
program inside and out.
And I know that she's as
passionate about this community
as I am and that
she's going to be
a great advocate for you guys.
Sorry.
These are actually
tears of gratitude,
because I'm so grateful
for the opportunity
to work with all of you.
When I took this job, I said
that it was just amazing.
I never thought that
I would get paid
to do something that
I love like this
and to work with so
many incredible people.
It's been a real gift,
these last four years.
Actually, the whole
seven years I've
been involved with
it, but particularly
these last four years, where
I could spend all my energies
on this.
But if there's something I
wanted to teach you all--
and people ask me
about this, about how
do I get to work at
Google-- and I said,
don't worry about
working at Google.
Find what you're passionate
about and do that.
And if that lead you to
Google, that's a plus.
But if it doesn't
lead you to Google,
you're still doing
what you love.
And I was just fortunate
enough that what I love
brought me here.
And at this point in
my life, a new passion
has really come up for me
around mindfulness practices,
and there was this
unique opportunity
to do that at Google and
leverage my community
experience.
So it was just, again, another
opportunity I couldn't pass up.
Otherwise, they would have to
drag me kicking and screaming
from this job.
So the thing I
wanted to say there
is that what made this
really easier for me--
it's still hard-- was
knowing that Adriana
was ready to step
in and be solely
in charge of this program
and take it forward.
And I want to strongly
encourage you, number one,
to follow your passions.
And if they lead you away
from GDG communities,
so be it, because
it's more important
that we have passionate
people in the communities.
And I know those of you
that are in there now
are passionate about
this but, your passions
will change just like mine have,
and you need to follow those.
But in order to be
able to do that and not
leave your communities
stranded, you
need to be building a
community of leadership.
You guys need to become
meta-community managers, just
like Adriana and I are
meta-community managers.
You need to be
coaching and building
other community leaders
in your communities
so that when the time comes
for you to go on to new things,
you can do that knowing that
your community will be fine.
In fact, I wouldn't be here--
I want to actually take
this point to thank
Kevin Nielson,
because if he hadn't stepped
up when I needed help
with the Java user
groups in 2006--
I was starting to
get burned out.
I would have probably
stopped doing community work
altogether, but because Kevin
came on board, I got energized.
Not only did I do
the Java work, I
started doing the
Google Technology Group
work with Kevin's help.
That led to this job.
Similarly-- I don't share
this publicly, but I am now.
In 2000, after I started
this job, it was my dream job
but it was a very
challenging job
and I was feeling really
burned out by it about a year
or two into it.
And that's when
we hired Adriana.
And I was seriously thinking
about leaving the job.
Not because I didn't love the
work, but it was just killing
me physically,
emotionally, doing the job.
And it was with her support
that I was able to then, again,
get reenergized.
You need to find good people.
I've been fortunate in finding
those good people in my life
to work with that support
me in following my dreams,
even if it takes
me away from them.
So I want to encourage you all
to do that in your lives, too.
And I guess with that, I'll just
turn it back over to Adriana.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO:
Van, first off I just
want to thank you for
all the amazing work
that you've done
with the community.
Obviously without you, this
global program wouldn't exist.
Van, as you all know-- or
maybe those of you that are new
don't-- he was a pioneer
for the GDG program.
Before that, it was really
just an idea in a few cities.
And because of his
passion around this work,
Google basically poached him to
create this global community.
And it basically went
from two groups to now
we have over 550 globally.
It's really amazing.
Van-- I think he
already knows this,
but it's just so
you all know-- he's
seen as a leader and
thought-leader in the community
space as a Community
Manager here within Google.
People come to him asking
for expertise and support
on programs that
they're running.
It's really amazing to see.
And selfishly, I'm glad that
he's staying within Google
to do community work, because
I personally as a Googler
am going to reap the benefits
of the awesome community
that he's now going to be
creating around mindfulness.
At the same time, I'm obviously
really going to miss you, Van.
It's been an amazing two
years working with you.
Not only on a
professional level.
Also on a friend level.
Obviously that's not
going to go away,
and I'm so glad your
staying within Google.
But I also want to
take this moment
to thank you for all the
mentorship that you gave to me.
I did have community
manager experience when
I came into this role,
but it was really
through the tutelage,
I guess you can say,
of Van over the last
two years working
with a really passionate
awesome community that's
organically growing
around the world
to understand what community
management is really all about.
And without that, I would not
have the wealth of expertise
that I currently have.
And that being said, going
forward I will certainly
still use Van as my consultant
as I have a hard decisions
to make, and working on this
program-- on this community--
and continuing to grow it.
And on that note, I want
to reassure everybody
that, as Van said,
nothing's changing here.
I will be your main
Program Manager, or really,
Community Manager at Google
for this global program.
However, things will continue
to be carried out just
as they have been, because
whenever I have a decision
to make and I'm not sure
about how to go, I ask myself,
what would Van do?
I actually had that
thought just yesterday.
So thank you for all
your amazing work.
And I know that you will be,
obviously, sorely missed.
Not only by myself, but by the
awesome community out there.
But I am also really excited
to be leading the program,
to taking this forward, and
having an amazing 2015 year.
We have a lot of great
things coming ahead,
and I just urge you all to
keep doing what you're doing
and know that this program
is in a great position
and has more eyes
on it internally
from Google than ever before.
It's the sole channel for
reaching developers globally,
and so that's a really
powerful place to be
and it's very much valued.
So I'm really looking forward
to all the opportunities
and resources that's going to
be coming through this year.
You can stay tuned by
the end of this month
to get an update on what's
to come for this year
directly from me.
And also, please continue to
be nice and work with Sara,
as she's going to be my
co-pilot going forward.
So thank you, Van.
Thanks to everybody.
And we will surely be in touch.
If you have any questions
or concerns about this,
please feel free
to reach out to me.
You all still have Van's
email address, as well.
I urge you to reach
out to him, as well.
We're both here as
resources for you.
VAN RIPER: Yes, I'm still
happy to hear from any of you.
If it's a specific thing
about running the GDG
support from Google,
that needs to go
through Adriana going forward.
But whenever you're
in Mountain View,
I'd love to see you for lunch.
Have a great 2015, everyone.
ADRIANA CERUNDOLO: Bye-bye.